[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
hello everyone and welcome to another
first look video at a game called dice
legacy now
the reason why i am telling you about
this game it is because it is amazing
alright so first of all my name is pete
also knows now though here and this
developer by the name of destiny bit
gave us a key to be able to
play this game now
in this video i have some portions sped
up because um it is a very slow paced
game or i should say
i play a slow paced game not so much the
game itself it's more of me playing so i
ended up speeding up a good portion of
it but
the way this works is you start off with
six dice
you roll the dice and each dice
obviously has six sides to it and each
do different things
one is utility one is a
scavenge or i should say
look in an area
um one is fighting one is building
one is um
i think no i think two of them are the
same
so you have the utility and uh and um
scavenging an area the same but anyway
so the point of the matter is is that
you go through this game
and you are rolling your dice to be able
to do certain things that are involving
the map itself
oh the map
first of all the map is on a curve
which you
do not exactly uh expect but at the same
time when you get it it is amazing uh it
is really really cool done uh there's a
fog of war past a certain area there's
so many different aspects of the game um
that i want to talk about so i'm gonna
try to talk about uh as many of the
different aspects of the game uh while
while while we're here so
um first thing um
you you start off as just
six lonely peon dice
uh and what you end up having to do is
you end up having to
um
you know scavenge
wood ice oh wood ice wood iron um food
and things like that over time you can
start building certain things for
instance you can build farms you can
build houses you can build
um
what is that called the
schools uh
you can build a um an area for you to
upgrade um your your dice
to tonight's um
you have you know um a
church for for you to turn them into
monks
you have so many different things the
school you can turn them into citizens
uh you can also make them go into like a
merchant area to learn how to become a
merchant so you have this really really
cool way that you can kind of take these
dicey six dice
and then push them into being
different types of type of dice now the
interesting and cool part about that is
that
you can end up making more dices you can
have a total of 12 and you can kind of
figure out how you're going to place
those so
for instance you're going to want to
have like one or two of the night dice
around you're going to want to have a
couple of the um the citizen ones around
because with the citizen ones you put
them at the school you learn new traits
new abilities new things to make your
life easier uh the monk one inspires
your dice to make them stronger your
merchant one ends up having you end up
doing more merchant type things
now
the graphics on this is
very well done because the
the ana like how should i say the
animations of things going on in the
world are beautifully ended up done you
can see like trees moving and and the
rustling of um the water you can see all
of those amazing things that are are put
into this game and then the buildings
themselves are built out to be
uh looking beautiful cottages and homes
and markets and things like that
now
um i played for many hours and i still
haven't gotten past the first board
which either proves to you all that this
is either a very difficult game or i'm
just terrible at playing it
but at the same time i'm getting such a
huge amount of enjoyment out of it and i
think that
you all will will do that too you all
get a huge amount of enjoyment so the
when you're going up the
up the map it's
fogged out so you can't really see it so
you have to end up putting more um like
government buildings down to be able to
see more
and over time you know you have to kind
of learn to take care of your back your
back row in addition to your front row
so you have to kind of go back and forth
and
you have to
work very quickly in doing that
now
the
interesting part about it is you have
the regular seasons you have you know
your your uh your winter your spring
your summer and your fall now during the
fall time they tell you hey falls
winter's coming
you might want to be able to store some
food
so you make sure you take as much weed
as possible and you end up either
getting as much wheat as you possibly
can or straight food the reason why you
want the straight wheat is because you
can take them to the bakery and you can
end up making food that way
so you have all of these
little aspects of the game that are
going to end up
making it so you have
um
little tweaks to the game that you want
for instance if your knights get injured
or your dice should say in general get
injured you can end up putting them at
the uh the herb the herbalist
or alchemist i should say and he'll end
up fixing them up the problem is that
you need the herbalist to go find the
herbs so you can either put them next to
a bunch of different
forests
or you can find specific forests that
have herbs in them
now if you
are
mining the wood in those forests you can
deplete the wood and then they're gone
and then you have no option for your
herbs
or you can just pray that you find more
herbs in the way so you have all these
decisions that you need to make that are
going to make you want to play the game
over and over and the game and the
placement of all the tiles
are
always different so you get to place
your tiles however which way you want
or or i should say your buildings
however which way you want but the ones
in the map itself are always changing so
you don't exactly know uh which is
really really a cool aspect of the game
which gives it a really really high
replayability and i really i really love
this game i can't tell you how much i
wanted to keep playing it and playing it
so
um so once again this is pete also knows
now though here giving you all a first
look at uh dice legacy um you can go
ahead and check the iron alerts podcast
out
on um
on a saturday i'm sorry not saturdays
not sundays uh on sundays and uh you
know you can check myself out on monday
to friday on twitch if you're looking to
do that so uh and if you have any
questions comments or anything please
make sure you state them below and uh we
will get right to you uh with an answer
all right well thank you very much and
i'm telling you pick up this game it is
so much fun and you'll have you know
you'll have fun for hours so thanks
again everybody have a great week bye
everybody
uh you
whoa
[Music]
this is this and then we're gonna add
two gold to it
to make it bigger
[Music]
[Music]
where is our technology tree
forgot how to open it up
there is the light bulb
all right
increases wheat produced by the farm by
one
rations cookouts restores for more
durability
[Music]
um
i think that's really good for us
because it'll give us less time for them
having to cook having to eat and having
to do that so
we'll see what comes back frozen it
doesn't
but this these things these dice now are
going to be coming back with
so much extra
16 so it can go
anything under an eight right eight
[Music]
you